Maurice Hoshi has a special guest in
Zagreb yes sorry I was just chatting
with our special guest
leshenka DBA who is the minister of
science and education for Croatia and
this lady's accomplishments is just
ridiculous she's got a master's in math
in fuel mathematics master's in physics
a PhD in mathematics she's written over
seven she's written seven books 50
papers
I guess she's slightly qualified for the
job she's here with us enjoying the
chest as well welcome to the show
first of all let's talk about how proud
you guys are of chess being here in
Zagreb in Croatian yeah that's right so
it's really exciting having a lot of
actually the best of the best of the
chess players here in Croatian Zagreb I
think it's very good for not just for
promoting chasing Croatia but to make
racial visible on the map of the world
Mehmet racism question everybody's
thrilled Xiamen enjoy Zagreb without any
question as the Minister of science and
education you must see a connection
between what you do and chess yes of
course because now we're in the middle
of the reform of our educational system
and what we would like to see it is much
more emphasis in education on problem
solving algorithmic thinking and that's
wonderful because chess is the really
not chess as a game but as a tool to
develop logical thinking and
problem-solving skills and all Greek
algorithmic thinking in you know schools
for our kids and that's very important
for the 21st century so I think it is
great now we know you're a mathematician
and all that great stuff but do you play
chess that's what we want yeah actually
I I was I was very very thrilled with
chess when I was a girl and probably
that helped me at that time to develop
my logical skills and mathematical
skills as well and as far as I can see
it we we should work much more on
introducing chests in our schools no as
I said just chess is a game but chess is
a tool to develop this kind of skills
problem solving skills and algorithm
algorithmic skills I remember their last
chest a lot of em nowadays I'm a little
bit ashamed because I'm I haven't
developed this skills later on but
you're doing slightly busy by the way
you are the boss why can't you just put
yes right into the curriculum yeah
that's that's how that word I discussed
it Gary just a few minutes ago that how
many possibilities we have now because
we're in the middle of reform and we can
introduce a lot of new ideas coming from
the chess world to the curricula and
vice versa
how we can promote chess and use chess
as a promoter for for this higher order
cognitive skills in schools I think with
you and Gary on the job we can consider
it as good as done we know I read also
that you went to Duke University or work
with Duke yes it worked also with the
University of Pennsylvania Penn State
but also with 20 20 more than 20 years
ago I spent some time also an investor
of Kentucky and it was it was really
wonderful experience for me but it was
by my foot first for first time in 1997
I was in US and it was great well we all
we heard you mention that when you were
two dude there was some NBA players that
played back in the day he sure has some
players who made it to the NBA been
quite successful yeah yeah we were and
we still are at 20 20 years ago it was
probably you know version Petrovic also
Raja and Kukoc very famous at that time
not just in Europe but
in NBA because they play there and
nowadays I think it was Bogdanovich hey
Sonia shortage as far as I remember but
probably some more little Croatian
producing all those stars well thank you
so much for joining us keep up the good
work and you know we expect to see chess
in the curriculum yeah thank you thank
you thank you the boss yeah I try to do
my best
thank you absolutely well blah gingka
DPI to the minister of sports and
education here in croatia science and
education is an education
[Laughter]